joins us now i love that scene that's
fantastic i have no idea who you are we
know who you are though and we're very
happy that you're here because you were
at the oscars last night and you got on
a plane to be here in person and we
appreciate it and you took a red eye
ready you didn't even go to the hotel
you came here no i literally i couldn't
even uh i know it's going to sound kind
of glamorous but i had to take a
helicopter and make it in time oh my
gosh so i but i'm i'm very happy that i
was able to make it um because uh it's
just it's just always fun to uh to be
here with you but let's linger on the
oscars for a moment we'll talk about
ncis but it's got to feel pretty good uh
to win an oscar or be part of a film
that won an oscar what does it mean to
you oh it's unbelievable especially
especially with this film you know what
what this film is brought to so many
families and so many communities how
it's united so many communities under
this little latin family so many
different types of people from around
the world saw themselves in this family
and for them to be commemorated on that
stage and and for our culture to be so
loud on that stage it's something that's
beautiful and i hope it's a beacon that
we can open the door and continue to see
more of these stories i hope so too
because you you we were talking before
we went on camera you weren't in the
room last night when the slap heard
round the world happen you were already
in the car heading out
yes yes yeah
i was already helicopter yeah yeah no i
was i was uh and nowhere uh i was
nowhere near it i was already on my way
to the airport to come and see you guys
yeah because up until then though it had
been a really good night hadn't it been
because i think so people so many people
were so glad to be out and dressed to
get out in the world and mingle and
celebrate what hollywood is really all
about i think i think it was a it was a
beautiful night i think that when you
when you do the the math and all the
moments that that we saw all the voices
that were heard i mean all the the
awards that that were so well deserved i
mean you had a lot of first times yes on
that stage and to be in that room for
for that energy was absolutely
incredible we knew it was a historic
knife for sure i know what does it mean
that encanto has been because lynn was
here sitting in the chair where you're
sitting actually what does it mean that
it's been so embraced how does that feel
to you personally to be part of
something it's incredibly humbling and
just to speak on lin-manuel who's one of
our champions and one of our leaders and
in this movie and and you know and our
directors jared and byron and and uh
teresa i i got to tell you um
the the thoughtfulness that went into
this film you know and to and to know
that it was special but not
understanding how necessary it was in
this moment yeah how much we needed this
moment
um is something that's just uh it's
forever you know it's forever you know
what it's a moment we didn't even know
we needed yeah yeah yeah uh let's talk
about ncis right okay so uh agent torres
is going to be going to hawaii where he
will meet agent tennant yeah to help
solve a crime there what more can we
learn
is vanessa lashay yes it turns out that
that torres had actually met uh tenet
before uh wow there's a lot in that
smile right there a little bit of uh
there's a little bit of a history
between wow yeah so and it's it's
hilarious because you know uh vanessa
and i known each other from the mtv days
i had a little show on mtv called your
mama she was a dj on trl so we used to
do interviews all the time and now
finding ourselves full time in hawaii i
mean full circle in hawaii was was so
funny you're sort of a renaissance man
because you're going to be working on
zarro you want to play zorro you've
always zoro was an inspiration to you
why i mean it's
you know as
a lad man we had very few uh you know
few uh characters that we grew up saying
like oh i could be the hero too yeah and
he was the one that that made me feel
that way to have an opportunity to
partner up with walt disney and
um and you know create a
grounded and authentically historical
version where we can retell our stories
you know uh who we were in california
before uh before uh history took place
it's just awesome it's just beautiful i
mean i'm telling you it's it's surreal
and i'm very proud to to take that on
from
the two-hour special tonight's gonna be
awesome as well you can watch it ncis
crossover event 9 8 central here on cbs
and streaming on paramount plus